I saw you today for the first time in
person since Leo came out and I felt
emotional because I'm so happy for you
you're my friend but also I was saying
you and I have collaborated on so much
stuff and there's there's a lot of noise
out there and I'm very proud of the
stuff we've worked on together but I'm
so I saw this thing and I thought oh
this is going to be a movie that kids
are watching and with their parents
because it's really funny they're going
to be watching it like 50 years from now
you no I don't know how they'll be
they'll be putting drops in their eyes
and watching it but but no I I just it's
really uh I think it's lasting I think
it's a classic and I was just delighted
just really delighted for you cuz Jesus
you know you deserve it um and it's like
it it feels like the first thing I've
ever done that everyone agreed on at the
same time like you know our show was
amazing and we loved it more than
anything and there was an audience that
got it there's always and and I've had
you know and then little segments that
I've done like the cartoons on SNL but
any independent project that I've done
even the ones that were successful like
the Zohan or right Hotel Transylvania it
wasn't a critical success this is like
everything it's everything's coming
together yeah it's never happened to me
in my whole career so it's like it's
just
weird but I love it and I'm very excited
and um yeah I'm very happy and I it was
I really and it's four years my I know
it's been you've been working this for
four years you've been telling me about
it and I've been saying enough with the
talking where is it I know I it was
maddening and I would like go on Zoom
meetings like you know because like
first you animate it to like black and
white drawings animatics animatics and
you we tested it and it did great and
it's like great now make it do the whole
thing over and that was like the
creative process working with board
artists now you're converting the whole
thing to 3D and it's almost like okay we
just want it to be as good as the
animatic now like we've made most of the
creative decisions and it's just so
Technical and like sometimes there'd be
Zoom meetings where my other two
directors like my notes were usually
about acting and they'd be like Leo's
tail it has a little bump it's off model
and like that I would literally
just to be sane I would like mute myself
on the zoom and start making animal
noises just like what do you think
C and I would send it to friends with
like they would hear the meeting in the
background the cow doesn't like the idea
sorry you know we we uh the other thing
I should point out is you write the the
music in this there's a lot of there's a
lot of there's a lot of really great
songs in it oh that's nice and um but
it's it was fun for me because you and I
one thing we always had in common was we
always wanted sketches to turn into
songs I know just and so we we thought
sketches should have a theme song so
when we were working on Mr short-term
memory that was like the first we wanted
it to have a song Lauren was like can't
it just be because Don parto for years
would just be and now another episode of
shortterm memory man yeah and literally
said can't it just be an
hour and we we were like no it has to be
and and Odin Kirk and and and uh Greg
Daniels were working on this too but we
wanted we were like no no it has to be a
song Mr short-term memory he shouldn't
have sat under that pear tree and it's
Tom sitting under a pear tree and a pear
drops and hits him on the head now he
has no memory he'll frustrate you so but
he'll never know he's
Mr it was one of those things it was
like the first one yeah I I love the
Elegance of that first line and but then
that became like a a plague on the show
like everybody started putting Jingles
at the top of every every character
everything had to have a jingle
everything had a jingle but yes uh
actually I I would have to the the
biggest thrill of this movie on some
level is just the balls to write songs
and music like I was so scared to do it
on one hand but then I like I knew a
composer This brilliant composer David
yasbeck I I can't even play a musical
instrument I just sang These into Garage
Band and like and then I sent them to
him and I was like do these suck and he
was like no they don't suck and I was
like oh God the song at the end with all
the children saying how old they are
when I was 10 and like Blends into the
next age was amazing yeah that's that's
my favorite and um yeah I love it
because it's funny it starts out really
funny because the the premise is like
probably an old peanuts premise like a
kid thinking oh back when I was seven
things were you have no idea how what
you what you're looking right but um but
I just love like the the lyrics get are
very silly at first like you know we all
G left milk for Santa Claus my mom was
not in menopause and that kind of thing
it's all very like heartfelt and they're
in a spotlight and then it turns at one
point you know one girl's reminiscing
about her grandfather and my jales are
still alive it's still kind of funny and
then another kid says I didn't care that
people died which is something that's
based on something I experienced with my
son Roe who's also in the movie He plays
the uh whatever kid the the allergy kid
oh God the Drone kid but and he but
anyway such a great that I love the
Drone oh the drone's amazing when he
eats when he goes full Bridget Jones and
starts eating the chocolate ice cream
after a I love that thank you but so
rowy there so there when my dad passed
away my kids used to like laugh at the
idea of death I don't know if you have a
similar but my kids I still do well know
get over the shock and then it's like
realize how funny it is uh after your
own parents die no so no so row they
would they would like death man that
what is that all about and they giggle
about how weird it is when they were
like four and then like my dad passed
away when they were eight and he had a
long illness and a beautiful long life
so the part of me was relieved but the
thing that really made me cry was like
hearing roey experience it and cry he
was crying really hard I was with my mom
and so I spoke to him on the phone and I
realized that not only is he crying
because he adored his grandfather but
because he's taking in this right
reality so that part gets me every time
you know that's when that's when I get
emotional when I hear that song well
it's a uh absolutely beautiful movie and
um you're right it's like the it's nice
when it all comes together and uh I I
I'm looking at this Leo has had this is
crazy 34.6 million views in its first
six days I don't know what that means
but it it sounds like a
lot that's the biggest debut ever for a
Netflix animated film so uh that's I
mean as long as you have a big piece of
the merch you're okay uh
oops somehow I do
Lauren somewhere in Maine somewhere in
Maine a blueberry farm just got a little
bigger a blueberry farm right massive
blueberry farm you know the
and also this is like we have to do it
because we all do Lauren voices and make
Lauren jokes but you and I would be
completely unknown to anyone everybody
if it weren't for Lauren Michaels so
without a doubt we love we love him to
death we love him to death but we love
doing his voice we love doing his voice
the blueberries and then he has a giant
blueberry farm in main wait minut so
it's like and uh you know
the the blueberries um we don't sell the
blueberries because they're ripe we sell
them because it's 11:30 on Saturday
night well Robert I should probably wrap
this up but I there's got to be a part
two at some point cuz uh but thank you
for doing this I love you you changed my
life you keep changing it ruining it but
also making it better Mak then changing
it back y fixing smashing and then Joy I
want you to be happy for you you should
be I can't believe you could even say
that you're still nervous you are I'm
not nervous but it's like I'm so happy
for you because I think it's can I take
two seconds to just remember okay so I
remember like that summer Conan would do
these uh practice shows 1993 I'm talking
again and like Dino like a couple of
writers would be out there and there's
no audience and Conan would just be so
funny just relaxed on stage and
there was a part of me that was like why
do we have to have an audience why do we
even have to have an audience it's just
gonna get in the way and you know he
figured it out and obviously had an
amazing career on late night television
but this show is everything that you are
it's so amazing we get to see how smart
you are and thoughtful and spontaneously
funny and I'm over the moon for you that
you have this and how popular it is and
I I know that I know you're happy I I am
no no I am I I I I am very blessed I do
wish one thing sometimes which is I wish
there had been a camera or recording
going on in the writer rooms over the
years because I'll always think that was
my best work was after a late night show
in a in a room talking about
entertaining the writers I would do
whole shows for the writers and um
that's my best work and it will never be
known and uh but that's okay it's you
know it's fine this is uh this is really
close to that anyway uh love you
everyone has already seen Leo twice by
these metrics but go everyone go see it
nine times and congratulations thank you
masle thank mle filled with
mle